il y a longtemps quand j'avais 10 ans
j'ai découvert le premier album de cette
bande dessinée Elena
et je me suis dit oh mon dieu c'est quoi ce
truc je pense que c'était comme moi c'est le
conteur c'était la première fois et on
voit le couple moderne  ils agissaient
comme deux personnes normales aujourd'hui sauf
qu'ils sont au 28ème siècle et
tout est bizarre l'environnement était
juste fou
c'est comme des extraterrestres partout et le monde est
partout quand je travaillais sur le
cinquième élément avec le designer de mai de mi-année
de Berlin il était  celui qui dit pourquoi
ne pas faire de vinayan pendant que vous faites ce
truc du cinquième élément, je veux dire que la technologie n'était
pas bonne à l'époque, ce n'était pas possible
et comme bien plus tard l'avatar est arrivé sur l'
avatar rend tout possible, il
n'y a plus de limite mec je fais l'histoire
où le tournage est maintenant il y a 40 ans, avez-vous
déjà pensé que vous seriez transformé en
film sans commencer à travailler avec l'artiste
trois ans avant au téléphone de commencer
le storyboard un an et demi avant que
nous soyons si fiers  n c'est amusant de venir
au tournage semble presque facile
[Musique]
magnifique là-bas et Laura lein il y a
deux flics ton arme quand tu es un bon
garçon de travail et ils peuvent voyager dans l'espace et le
temps
tout le petit photographe indépendant prétentieux d'Ariana
Rebecca que diriez-vous  vous voulez
pour la sauvegarde juste changer c'était soit il
sauvera la situation tout est un peu
trop facile les amis pas plus que ce n'est
probablement mon premier amour 10 ans vous
savez que vous commencez à vous sentir serrer la
main et à vous lever que c'est agréable de
vous voir  vraiment pas beaucoup une belle
entreprise ils sont très humains gros combat
et il est désespérément amoureux d'elle
univers
bienvenue dans alpha alpha appelée la ville
des mille planètes parce que toute la
connaissance de l'univers est là la
station Alpha a 3236 espèces avec plus de
5000 langues parlées il Wall Street
yukio espionne United  Les nations ont
tout emporté là-dedans, donc cela fait de la ville
la plus importante de toute l'
université,
cela a toujours été mes rêves avec leur
personnage est le grand écran et maintenant c'est
le moment où
sur le cinquième élément il y a 188
coups d'effet de patrouille
mon nom est  la valériane il y a 2734 a chargé
mon lot fourrière pour me faire arrêter et le
voyage a été fait je lui ai donné
tout ce que j'avais et j'ai hâte de le
partager avec vous alors amusez vous
[Musique]
vous